[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
the first view from 22 of
2024 and I am delighted to be joined by
Peter wood who is president of the
National Association of Scholars in
America and we're going to be talking
about another scholar uh of sorts uh
Claudine gay who resigned this week as
president of Harvard following
accusations of
plagiarism um Peter for our British
viewers and listeners uh could you just
give us a little bit of an overview of
the story because they they probably
haven't been following it too
closely yes uh a scholar named or a
journalist named Chris
rufo discovered and
published evidence that gay had
plagiarized portions of her Harvard PhD
dissertation from the late
1990s uh less than a day after that a
journalist at the uh Washington
U examiner I think it was uh published a
story in which uh he documented
extensive plagiarism in four of
President Gay's 11 public published
articles in academic
journals since that time others have
discovered additional instances of
plagiarism both in the journals the
dissertation and in other published
journals so half of her material now
more than half of her published uh
articles have documented plagiarism in
them and her dissertation has been
viated by academic
dishonesty well and I've seen that she's
written uh a response in the New York
Times and there's been lots of uh
comment in uh kind of what people like
to call Legacy Media uh about this story
suggesting that she was the victim of a
kind of right-wing hit job uh I mean she
said she was part of a of a broader war
that um conservatives are fighting a
broader culture War um what's your view
on
that well she's by no means a victim
she's a perpetrator but it is true that
there is something broader going on here
than simply the exposure of a dishonest
academic uh the story really involves
how um president gay was chosen to be
president of Harvard she had campaigned
for a number of years as a champion of
the diversity Equity inclusion movement
including a
u letter that she had written in August
of 2020 to the entire faculty of the
College of Arts and Sciences at Harvard
in which she laid out an ambitious plan
to uh eliminate the scourge of white
supremacy which she characterized as the
the second pandemic and this would
require using extensive racial
preferences in hiring faculty members in
um bringing in postgraduate fellows uh
student admiss s overall uh the
non-faculty staff of the University
would be selected and and promoted on
the FASTT trck on the basis of race and
she was concerned about the appearances
on campus of uh buildings named after
and portraits of white people that had
to be replaced in a manner that would
make uh people of color feel more
comfortable at the institution this was
a sort of breathtakingly broad idea of
transforming Harvard University
University from a place that prioritized
The Pursuit Of Truth the uh 350 some
year old motto of the university is
Veritas and this was now to be uh an
institution that was primarily concerned
with uh Gay's version of social justice
and everything else would go by the
boards so what else is going on what
else is going on is an effort to push
back against this U Revolution at
Harvard yes do you think perhaps uh just
in terms of her mistakes uh just from a
purely careerist point of view not from
a moral point of view uh do you think
perhaps her bigger mistake was not the
uh white supremacy Dei stuff which
although I see there is a push back
against it this year and let's get on to
that uh her big mistake was to do with
October 7th and the response of Harvard
uh both on the campus and from the
authorities uh which gay was the
ultimate Authority as president uh that
that that Harvard was seen to be uh
endorsing anti-Semitism and that that
led to another push back against
her well the very same day that Hamas
engaged in its atrocities in Israel
later that day a bunch of Harvard
students came forward representing I
think it was 34 student organizations
pronouncing that Hamas was in the right
and this was an appropriate action to
take against the colonial power of
Israel
um when that happened Gay's immediate
response was to defend the rights of
free speech of these pramas
demonstrators and saying not a word
about the danger they posed calling for
the murder of Jews to Jewish members of
the faculty and student body at Harvard
um the reaction to her
uh noninterest in that important detail
was very very Swift and within about
another day of that she issued a a
temporizing statement in which she
seemed to be saying that well mass
murder is not quite as good as I thought
it was but and we do need to defend the
Jewish students at Harvard that didn't
sit well either it was seen as an anemic
response to a very grave provocation and
uh soon after she issued yet another
statement uh which had a little bit more
spine in it but not that much I think
she was correctly seen by the the Jewish
community at Harvard as a not a friend
but maybe somebody who could be pushed
into saying at least a few things in
support of uh fairness and Justice and
that was about it that's how things
stood there there were a significant
major donors to Harvard University who
pulled back their money there was a
flurry of criticism at least least in
the conservative press in the US but she
didn't back down in any significant way
at all and that went forward into until
her uh testimony along with two other
college presidents at the uh House of
Representatives committee on education
in the workforce where a congresswoman
from New York elen stefanic asked her
some pointed questions about whether it
was in violation of Harvard's
anti-harassment policy to allow death
threats to be made against the the
Jewish students and Dr Gay at Harvard
does calling for the genocide of Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no anti-semitic
rhetoric when it anti-semitic rhetoric
anti-semitic rhetoric when it crosses
into conduct that amounts to bullying
harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action
so the answer is yes that calling for
the genocide of Jews violates Harvard
code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the
board she could not find it in herself
to say that there was uh any significant
violation of Harvard's disciplinary
policy policies uh her answer there
where she echoed the two other college
presidents was that it depends on
context and stefanic appropriately asked
in what context is it appropriate to
call for genocide for which she really
had no answer at all well that leads us
on to uh a rather sensitive area which
uh people um are very nervous to tread
on so perhaps we should be too but and
that's uh the anti-Semitism of black
leaders in in America uh often on the
Progressive radical left um and for
decades a lot of people say uh these
figures have gotten away with saying uh
quite viciously anti-semitic things and
that's no longer the case or seems to be
stopping a little bit would you
say well it's put the breakes on the
anti-Semitism that is a I'm don't not
sure it's an ancient part of the Black
American Community but it's been
longstanding
we had anti-semitic riots in the black
community here in the 1960s and70s and
it's uh it's sort of deeply rooted
within uh that Community
the um I I would not go so far to say
that all the prominent black leaders in
the US uh have a covert anti-semitic
agenda but some do and those are the
ones who are most prominent on the left
at the moment we also have the issue of
U the 1619 project the New York Times
celebrated journalist Nicole Hannah
Jones U we have a tanesi coats between
the world and me Memoir that he puts
forward which essentially claims that
all of White America is racist and then
ibram X kendi whose uh work has launched
the um the idea that anti-racism in
involves
installing a regime of racial
preferences that is pro black now those
are probably the three leading
intellectual figures if they can be
called that um in the American black
community and all three of them uh
traffic in at least undertones and
sometimes rather explicitly in
anti-Semitism uh and and that's not to
mention people like Jesse Jackson who's
had a very long history of anti-Semitic
U maneuvering in his public
statements Christopher ruer the
journalist who sort of first uh exposed
gays plagiarism uh you mentioned him
earlier he uh has already been accused
of being a Russian spy I think uh for
his for his journalism on this um which
I suppose is fairly typical but he also
has written uh a very interesting essay
quite a radical essay um in a new um
conservative uh magazine called IM
1776 and I don't know if you've seen
that essay but it really is quite
radical so much so that you can't really
necessarily say it's conservative and I
think even within the piece he addresses
that that uh he thinks the time has come
for uh the leftwing Takeover of
America's institutions is so complete uh
that the right no longer needs
conservatism they need a new kind of
radicalism to March back through the
institution
and I suppose a lot of people will see
his uh scalp as uh as it's been called
controversially of Claudine gay as as a
first blow in his War um against
America's Progressive woke
institutions well first I'm not familiar
with that particular essay although I
know Christopher and have read quite a
bit of his other writings so I I get
that idea um my own organization the
National Association of Scholars is
devoted to reform of higher education
not its uh eradication and replacement
although uh I have many members who have
some sympathy for the idea that the
leftist uh control of the institutions
is now so deeply entrenched that uh
something fairly radical will be needed
to displace it um I should say that
Christopher was by far the first on the
scene to report the plagiarism he wasn't
the first to notice it uh that was back
in October when several of us had hands
on this material and we're working to
find somewhere in the mainstream press
uh that would agree to publish it the
newspaper here in New York City the New
York Post had the material uh they
conferred with me about it and with
other Scholars who confirmed that it was
plagiarism but we scared off the story
because the uh Harvard
hit them with a an attorney who said he
would sue them for defamation if they
ran it so they were holding their peace
for a while so the word has been out
among a fair number of us that a major
plagiarism Scandal was in the offing we
were just waiting for the moment when
the story would broke and Christopher
was the first to do that and so sorry
just to confirm that's very interesting
you you people within the National
Association of Scholars had this
information as far back as when as uh
late last year uh no mid mid
October and I mean that's I can't help
noticing is a few days after uh October
7th and the r we were talking about then
uh there will be people who will
conclude that it may have been uh
non-journalistic actors providing that
information do you do you know whether
it was or wasn't um it was certainly
non-journalistic actors it was uh
professors academics who had uh first
taken notice of the uh plagiarized
material um but who were in no position
to uh bring it to public attention for
one thing bringing it the public
attention could be a career ending
movement uh by them so the effort was to
find some someone who could project it
to the public I was approached on this
because I'm independent I'm working as
the head of a a nonprofit organization
that works on academic reform but I
don't have command of the major media so
I could contact journalists but we were
really looking for a a major newspaper
that would say here's the material take
a look at it um Christopher rufo forced
their hand by putting out material and
then working hard to uh draw broader
public attention to it so hats off to
him well let's talk about this counter
Revolution that seems to be in the
offing and seems to be already a theme
of this year particularly with an
election uh coming up and the cultural
Wars that bound to surround that um
there does seem to be quite a lot of
energy on the right now for uh fighting
for not not violence um let's hope but
for uh fighting back is is Trump talked
about it a lot and a lot of trump Sports
talking about it but now it's not
necessarily um Maga Republicans or
whatever you want to call them it's uh
often very liberal people um who are
just Fed Up of um this Progressive
indoctrination in universities and this
Chokehold um that the the radical left
has over America's higher
institutions well a good number of the
supporters of my organization consider
themselves to be liberals uh we don't
identify with party or or with an ism
but uh clearly there is a a broad
disgust with the uh willingness of the
academic left to engage in censorship to
prevent the expression of opinions which
are at odds with uh what passes as the
party line for the moment but there's
also the issue of uh faculty members who
cannot get started in their careers or
continue in their careers because they
uh drift away from the established line
that brings us back to to the diversity
Equity inclusion business uh we deal
with faculty members uh right now I'm in
the midst of a case with a fellow at U
Ohio Northern University not a terribly
distinguished place but he decided that
he would oppose that institution's Dei
rules and for his efforts he was fired
as a tenure Professor to be fired is a
Rel relatively unusual thing in the US
but that shows you the the degree of
vehement with which the Dei agenda is
now Advance merely to question it is to
put your career at risk um or worse so
the uh this ferment leading to something
like revolutionary desire to change the
university is quite real uh it is not
however uh preeminent within any college
or university that I know about there
the Dei agenda The Fight Against Racism
as it is perceived is taken to be a
nearly holy cause which is uh grounds
for taking almost any kind of action
against the descenders So speaking for
the descenders which I will say are are
not simply conservative and they're
certainly not a merely a right-wing
Bunch although there is a right-wing
element to it uh we are the people who
think that American higher education
should be founded in The Pursuit Of
Truth truth that intellectual freedom is
a key value that understanding the role
of universities in uh helping to sustain
our civilization from generation to
generation are all great and good things
that uh those have become compromised by
a willingness to direct the energies of
the University into propagandizing
students in favor of various leftwing
causes uh is the essential problem now
we don't would all agree on what all
those issues are I mentioned the Dei
piece but there is also the question of
whether U climate alarmism has been
given too privileged a place on the
college campuses I'm among those who
think that the global warming uh talking
points have been wildly exaggerated uh
we have seen the uh way in which
universities and their faculties broadly
cooperated with the uh US government
govern's efforts to turn the covid
crisis into a mass hysteria U this is uh
one of a number of pieces one might
mention the willingness of universities
to embrace the cause of transgenderism
and uh various forms of radical feminism
which again become uh orthodoxies that
can crush the careers of anybody who
wishes as they should be able to to
descent to raise questions to express uh
admonition over our willingness to
accept talking points without evidence
and without good scrutiny of the
arguments put in favor of those causes
so all those things together wrap up
into a broad left-wing agenda that has
become uh too settled on the University
campus no one is calling for the uh
suppression of the people who favor
those views but to have those those
views treated as sacred cows that can't
be questioned at all has become
intolerable something has to change now
uh driving uh Claudine gay out of the
presidency of Harvard is a symbolic
Victory it doesn't amount to a great
change in Harvard itself which decided
to uh Overlook her plagiarism and move
her over to the political science
department where she could keep her
$900,000 a year salary
and continue to practice what looks to
most of us as a career of academic
dishonesty uh over 700 Harvard faculty
members signed a a letter agreeing to
support uh Claudine gay this is before
her resignation but it tells you that
the the rot is Broad and deep at Harvard
um and what it going on there is hardly
any different from what's going on at
America's other brandname universities
especially in the IV league and and of
course uh all the objections to her
dismissal or or resignation uh suggested
that uh the motive against her the
motives against her were racist and
racism um which is inevitable isn't it
that that is that is the
response well yes uh any of us who speak
out realize that if we get the better
argument we will be met simply with the
accusation that you are racist it has
been so overused that I think it has
lost most of its uh emotional power at
this point um we're indifferent to being
called racist because we know we're not
and uh racism here is merely the as uh
Dr Johnson said of patriotism being the
last Refuge of Scoundrels the accusation
of racism has become the last Refuge of
America's academic Scoundrels yeah
you mentioned uh tenure though tenure uh
Professor who's dismissed in spite of
his tenure um but I mean we well we both
know Roger Kimble I think who wrote the
book tenard radicals but today do you
not think that uh tenure is the the only
thing really protecting conservatives on
campus right well I have uh members of
my organization who are tenured
professors who plead with me don't
criticize ten because it's the only
thing keeping us in our positions my
answer to them is no it's not the only
thing that keeps you in your position is
your willingness to be outspoken in your
opposition because it's much more
difficult to fire a faculty member uh
who has become publicly identified as a
conservative than it is to fire a tenur
faculty member The tenur Faculty members
protections are proving to be very
flimsy uh and that's uh I think it's
it's just better to position yourself as
someone uh too publicly welln to be
fired than to go after the the uh Safe
Harbor of tenure it won't protect you
anymore and you say anymore just out of
curiosity is has something changed I
mean has the nature of tenure
changed well tenure is of course a a
legal fiction of sorts uh universities
have their uh rules of employment they
promise tenure to candidates who pass
very stringent tests but what we've seen
first of all was the dilution of tenure
in which individuals like Claudine gay
who by no stretch of the imagination
came close to meeting the standards for
tenure were given tenure that was often
times uh connected to racial privilege
that is uh treating blacks with a lower
standard of uh admissibility than others
um and then it spread that the the
ideologically U aligned groups that
could uh expect rightly I think the
allegiance of uh others in their uh
cohort uh were able to game the tenure
system to gain positions for people in
women's studies block studies Hispanic
studies queer studies and on down the
line with that dilution of what tenure
is to become a a blanket to protect
those in the uh category of grieved
minorities the use of tenure as a uh a
way to recognize the faculty members who
had risen to the traditional standards
uh was already weakened but then came
the realization that there were ways to
subvert their tenure U the favorite
tactic of the moment is to declare that
uh the the tenur faculty member who
speaks out on one of these sacred causes
uh is guilty of lack of collegiality a
lack of respect for fellow faculty
members or students and therefore
someone who trades in hate speech and is
a danger to the community so tene never
mind uh we need to protect uh people
from the terrible things that you might
think or say um now until as recently as
about a year ago that theory of a a
loophole and tenure had no legal status
but has now been tried in uh at least
one Court I think that was in North
Carolina where the court agreed with the
university yeah this is a good reason to
get rid of people the uh folks in Ohio
at Ohio Northern University who were
going after this law professor named
Scott Gerber are trying the same tactic
the reason to get rid of him is uh his
uh UNC collegiality and and what does
that consist of it consists of his
descending from the Dei Orthodoxy I
should mention that this particular
faculty member was uh a star teacher and
the most productive academic in the
whole university there with many books
and many peer-reviewed articles didn't
matter his his lack of collegiality
doomed him um we you've talked about Dei
there uh I I I mean I think I'm right in
thinking that Dei is sort of fruit of
Decades of affirmative action uh in
America or or the the the climax of it
in a way um because uh when America's
politicians uh started introducing
affirmative action measures uh in the
70s uh it was understood and it was
argued that this would not be a
long-term it wouldn't be necessary to to
do affirmative action in the long term
and that indeed if it were then it
should never be done um do you think
perhaps what we're seeing is that
affirmative action has run out of Road
uh because it's only hardened into the
Dei agenda um and actually the uh the
logical reasons for doing it have
gone well the the affirmative action
agenda ran out of Road a long time ago
uh in fact if you go back to the late
1970s it looked as though the Supreme
Court was going to say uh the sales of
that ship had to be trimmed that was the
famous Baki case um in which u a white
applicant to medical school with
Sterling credentials was turned down in
favor of several minority applicants um
and uh baky prevailed at the Supreme
Court but it produced this odd decision
in which one of the justices uh justice
Lewis Powell pronounced an opinion which
is said that the University of
California which was the institution
that had declined to admit Baki uh could
have won the case had it argued it on
different grounds that instead of uh
seeking social justice for minorities it
should have said that it was seeking
diversity and diversity would be
something that would enhance the
education of everyone black white and
otherwise uh because it was just a
better way to educate people um it took
higher education only a few years to
realize affirmative action had run out
of road so now they were going to switch
to diversity and diversity became the
calling card for racial preferences for
pretty much two decades um the the
diversity movement itself became uh such
a sham that people realize well this
isn't about admitting people who are uh
just in need of a helping hand and will
do just fine when they get here it
ushered in an era of double standards
and lower standards um so then we began
this slide over to well diversity itself
isn't getting us what we want so we will
add two more words to the list diversity
equity and inclusion all of these sound
like benign things but if you get to
know what they really mean they're not
so benign uh Equity means uh instead of
pursuing equality for people we are
going to pursue uh quality of outcomes U
if there are
uh 15% of the population that's black we
want to be sure that 15% of everything
in the University is also black um
inclusion is an even more mischievous
term what it means is that the standards
by which we judged you in the past are
no longer operative to be included is to
be judged by your own standards and the
standards of the black community may be
somewhat different from those of the
white community so there we we begin the
uh uh March into the idea that um it's
white privilege to expect honesty or
white privilege to expect timeliness or
privilege to uh grade people uh by the
results of uh a single test given
blindly to the whole
population my identity group deserves to
choose what its own standards will be
and that's what inclusion means you put
those three things together and it is
simply a wrecking ball for the whole
idea of a university based on
disinterested scholarship and pursuit of
Truth uh that's gone away cluding gay
for example when she was trying to
recover from her disastrous testimony at
the house education and Workforce
committee said that uh she had to speak
my truth as though uh her personal truth
was somehow different from the truth and
but there we are that's entirely
consistent with the Dei agenda a lot of
the argument for uh affirmative action
going into de has always been you know
if you can see it you can be it uh and
you know uh people of minority
backgrounds uh would uh Be Inspired um
by seeing people that look like them in
positions of power and
authority how do you respond to that is
that just more racial thinking uh
disguised as
progress yes it is just racial thinking
disguises Pro progress and anyone can be
inspired by anyone whose success uh
stands out as uh something to be
emulated and uh
the the idea that uh one might find
people with the same melanin level in
their skin as more inspiring than those
who aren't is certainly actively
promoted by the race hustlers in America
U but it's just not true the U we go
back to U the early 20th century when
web du Duo I think he says it the uh uh
author of Souls of black folks and one
of the first I think the first black
faculty member at Harvard uh begins his
his major work with uh
his confession that he can sit down with
Dante and Dante sees no color and
likewise the American Classics are open
to the American Classics are open to um
anyone who recognizes the classics as
such whether they're American or
european or African or otherwise um that
Readiness of the academic world to judge
people on the merits of their ideas is
really what's at stake with this notion
that you have to be inspired by someone
who looks like you or has some uh ethnic
uh connection to you um it's an
unfortunate lie and that it poisons the
minds of young people who say well why
should I bother if if I don't see uh a
sufficient number of likelook people in
positions of power well um we have had
people in positions of power uh one
might think for example of President
Barack Obama uh that doesn't seem to
have inspired a great outpouring of uh
renewed effort on the parts of young
black children to do better in schools
one can ask you know why not well there
are complicated social social social
reasons there to be taken into account
um the most important of which is the
breakdown of the black family uh the
fatherlessness of so many children and
you know we can ask why that is well
that goes back to the very beginnings of
affirmative action with the idea that um
the the black bis family was now to be
replaced by Aid to women with dependent
children and uh fathers were just a
recipe for losing welfare benefits
um a social history there that really
needs to be attended to carefully to
realize what terrible mistakes we've
made in Social Engineering over the last
more than half century that cannot
easily be undone at this point um if
you've grown up fatherless you're not
suddenly going to gain a father but um
the result of this has been a hugely
defensive attitude on the part of the
black community don't blame the victim
well um one does not want to blame the
victim but one has to realize that some
forms of victimhood are not easily
reversed and that uh the real challenge
right now is to figure out how to
construct a society that is more
Equitable in the genuine sense of the
word people deserve a fair chance at a
start in life and that requires policies
that are pratal that allow families to
arise and Thrive and give children hope
and ambition so that when they encounter
the difficulties of school and school is
difficult for a lot of children uh they
see themselves as obliged to meet those
difficulties and rise above them and if
there is uh and as as you've said that
we can't really be sure that there is a
genuine revolt against Dei happening uh
Across America yet uh but if there is
such a thing and it seems like that
there's certainly something going on um
I wonder I always ask you about your
book uh anger in America uh a be in the
mouth anger in America today um I think
uh I wonder how you feel about this new
sort of conservative activism or
right-wing activism that is quite angry
uh and is not willing um to settle for
anything less than Victory um does it
trouble you does it worry
you it worries me to the extent that the
um great Institution powers in America
not just the universities but the whole
Washington DC apparatus our law
enforcement authorities especially the
FBI uh appear to be uh spoiling for uh a
fight which will involve violence and
turmoil I I of course would much rather
see a peaceful transfer of power to the
more sensible portions of the American
populace uh it's going to be difficult
to have that peaceful transfer when the
FBI is busy uh locking people up for uh
crimes of sedition and of of uh
interfering with proper elections un
very suppositious grounds we are uh
seeing a system of U brute power being
marshaled against people who are
perfectly legitimate denters within uh
the American Republic and once you have
outlawed descent uh you are setting the
stage for revolt now I don't think that
Revolt arises primarily from Trump or
his supporters or anybody else on the
right I I think it arises from a uh
growing realization that they have been
denied a legitimate voice in the
governance of the country uh and by
governance I mean not simply uh how
elections are run but how our major
institutions are run we see over and
over again um whether it's uh the
Hollywood and the television world or
book publishing um the mass
media all seem to be aligned solidly on
the idea that U uh they call it our
democracy is at risk from having people
genuinely free to express their views
now I try to walk a careful line here I
do not want to be cornered into uh
supporting one party or candidate but I
certainly see that the anger in America
has a a legitimate uh base and that it
has been fed by the tactics of the
establishment uh to the point where we
easily could have a more serious
breakdown of order in the country um why
it is that uh President Biden and uh
others in his administration seem to
welcome that and are thirsting for the
uh the breakdown of such order uh
baffles me but I I understand that uh we
are headed in that direction so if
you're asking me if I'm worried the
answer is yes well on that uh uh
worrying note uh we'll end it there
thank you very much uh Peter wood uh
thank you very much for coming on to the
view from 22 please come on again uh in
this year of Elections and possible
counter
[Music]
revolutions